[MUSIC]
Hey there!
So, I was just calling to
say you're doing great work.
You got your fist bit of custom
data written into database.
And it only took a few minutes.
[MUSIC]
JP is calling.
Hey JP, we just wrote our
first data to Firebase.
And we didn't even have to
write a single Async task or
need to deal with threads.
>> I'm glad you like it.
>> Yeah actually, while I have
you on the phone, quick question.
So you've looked at the dashboard
longer than I have.
So how is data actually
structured in Firebase?
It doesn't look like
a relational database to me.
So what is this Firebase
data that I'm editing?
>> Well, you're right about it
not being a relational database.
So let me show you what it looks like.
Let me pull up my screen.
First, SQL has a tabular format with
columns and rows, like Excel or
a Google spreadsheet.
However, in Firebase,
data is stored in JSON.
It's basically a simple declarative
language used to describe
objects and data.
It's a lot more flexible
than a tabular format,
since you don't need to strictly
define rows or headings.
JSON contains a nested
structure similar to XML.
And also like XML, JSON can be
represented in a tree structure.
>> Yeah, I remember JSON from
working on developing Android apps.
I think it was the format that
both OpenWeatherMap API and
the movies database returned.
>> Hm.
And if your developer's
unfamiliar with JSON,
take a moment to close this hangout and
check out the links provided in the
instructor notes to get you up to speed.
>> All right, so
if I'm understanding you right,
the dashboard is basically
a visualization of my JSON tree.
And the Firebase object that we're
calling methods on in the Android
code that's also an object
representation of a JSON tree, right?
>> Yep.
>> Hm, okay so what kind of things can
I actually store as values in JSON?
It looks like here I stored a string
as a key and a string as a value, so
does that mean that any type that
JSON normally accepts is okay?
>> Right, let me explain.
Well yes mostly,
the keys are always strings.
The values stored in the tree
can be passes in as Booleans,
longs, doubles, lists, maps, and
some specific types of objects.
There are also Java types that
can be returned from the tree.
List and maps can contain more lists and
more maps.
And objects can contain other objects or
lists of other objects,
meaning you can have nested data
structures within data structures.
I know the dashboard is pretty powerful
when you want to look at your data,
although it's hard to tell when
you don't have too many entries.
Here's a look at it right now.